so maybe we shouldn't have used that
much hand sanitizer in our alcohol video
it's Michelle from lab muffin Beauty
science chemistry PhD and slight
hypochondriac I just want to be pure so
there's a bit of a pandemic going on
right now Tsarskoe vici is a corona
virus which causes the disease covered
19 which is spreading at an alarming
rate worldwide this disease usually
causes mild symptoms and most people
especially if you're young and healthy
but in older people it has a much higher
rate of hospitalization and death it
also gets passed along pretty easily
which is why it's a good idea to try to
slow down the transmission this idea is
commonly referred to as flattening the
curve so that hospitals don't get
overwhelmed with too many patients and
so they can give everyone the help they
need one of the ways that this current
virus can get passed along is through
your hands so you might touch a surface
which has the virus then touch your
hands or nose or mouth and that then
infects your respiratory tract and even
if you're not in a high risk category
it's often not a very pleasant disease
to have and you risk passing it on to
people who are more vulnerable so a lot
of health authorities around the world
are recommending that everyone washes
the hands for at least 20 seconds with
soap and water and to use hand sanitizer
when this isn't possible naturally a lot
of people have been buying up hand
sanitizer and not just for making a
video about alcohol in skincare which
means that in some places there's a
shortage and so there's a lot of DIY
hand sanitizer recipes going around and
homemade hand sanitizer being sold and
some people just want to avoid the
chemicals that go into hand sanitizers
by making their own now I think most
people who are sharing these recipes are
doing this with good intentions there
are some people of course who are just
trying to make a quick buck but making a
hand sanitizer that works is not quite
as easy as it sounds a commercial
product is much more reliable it's very
very easy to mess up a DIY recipe and
some of these DIY recipes just probably
aren't going to work even if you make
them perfectly and if you use the hand
sanitizer that you think is working even
though it isn't then you are putting
yourself at risk so I'm going to go
through
the hand sanitizer recipes I've seen
online and tell you whether or not
they're going to work spoiler alert a
lot of them aren't going to work if you
like the sort of video click the thumbs
up subscribe to my channel and click the
notification barrel so you don't miss
any videos first let's start with a
recipe that will work if you make it
properly the World Health Organization's
hand sanitizer recipe firstly note that
these recipes are for making 10 litres
which most of us don't need also note
that the World Health Organization says
these recipes are meant to be used when
you don't have a commercial product
around commercial products contain lots
of inactive ingredients which help the
product work better so for example a
thickening agent which makes it easier
to spread on your hands so there are
three components in these hand sanitizer
recipes firstly there's a high alcohol
concentration you need a high alcohol
concentration 60 to 95 percent to
reliably destroy viruses this alcohol
concentration is high enough to break
down the envelope around the corona
virus and to denature the proteins
inside it so that it can't infect you
the other two ingredients are glycerol
and hydrogen peroxide
lissa roll which is more commonly known
as glycerin in beauty products is a
humectant moisturizer it's there to keep
your hands most rice because alcohol can
dry out your skin other moisturizing
ingredients will also work for this but
it's best to use something water-based
alcohol-based hand sanitizers don't work
that well on greasy hands the grease can
help protect viruses so it's safest not
to use something oil-based hydrogen
peroxide is also included at a low
concentration and this is there to help
kill any remaining bacterial spores in
your ingredients or on your equipment
it's not actually there to help actively
kill any germs on your hands in the
World Health Organization guide to
making these hand sanitizers there's a
lot of advice on things like sterilizing
your containers and quality control
these are important if you want to make
a hand sanitizer that will sanitize your
hands properly if all you care about is
whether or not it can kill the current
virus then these are a bit less
important what you really need is that
high alcohol concentration and apart
from a high alcohol concentration pretty
much nothing else is considered
effective against the current virus as
of now and this includes things like
benzalkonium chloride another
ionic detergents that you find in
alcohol-free hand sanitizers these work
well against bacteria but generally not
so well against viruses which is why
health authorities recommend using an
alcohol-based one where possible so
unsurprisingly essential oils aren't
considered effective even if whoever's
selling them to you is saying otherwise
even if an essential oil has been found
to be effective against one type of
virus it doesn't necessarily mean that
it's going to be effective against this
brand new corona virus the corona virus
is not the same as a flu virus and even
if an essential is effective against the
current virus the concentration is
really important just like for alcohol
if there isn't enough it's not going to
work and that data just doesn't exist
yet we don't know how much essential oil
we need to kill corona virus for some
oils maybe even a hundred percent isn't
enough this applies to all the essential
oils you see they use oil tea tree oil
lavender oil lemon essential oil so
anything without alcohol you pretty much
can't trust so that means all of these
recipes that are some variation of
something with a few drops of essential
oil added to it with no alcohol they
will not work and you'll see tons of
these so aloe vera with essential oil no
water and aloe vera gel with essential
oil nor fractionated coconut oil with a
central or no boiled water with
essential oil No so a lot of these
recipes use something called de terras
OnGuard
and interestingly they do have an on
guard sanitizing mist and the reason it
works and that they can sell it as a
sanitizing mist is because it contains a
ton of alcohol in addition to the
essential oils it's the alcohol that
lets them make this claim not the
essential oils I think one of the
hardest things to work out when it comes
to a DIY hand sanitizer recipe is the
final concentration of alcohol when you
hear that health authorities recommend
at least 60% alcohol they mean 60%
alcohol in the final hand sanitizer this
doesn't mean that you can use anything
with 60% alcohol and toss it into a
recipe and it will work if you put a
drop of 60% alcohol into a giant tub of
aloe vera that is not going to work
sixty percent is three parts and five
which is pretty close to two parts to
one so if you're using 95 or 99% alcohol
and you're using two parts to one then
chances are you are above 60% you're
pretty close to 2/3 which is 67% so for
example this common recipe that I've
been seeing around will actually give
you a high enough concentration of
alcohol but if you mix in a lower
concentration of alcohol then your final
concentration in the recipe will be
lower so here's a table showing you what
happens when you use a less concentrated
alcohol product to make this recipe you
can see the lowest you can use is 90%
I'd recommend using a higher
concentration or adding a bit more
alcohol because some of the alcohol will
evaporate during the process and during
storage and after you start using it
I've calculated the minimum milliliters
you need per hundred milliliters of
final hand sanitizer that you need for a
lot of common concentrations of alcohol
products and these will give you the
minimum sixty percent alcohol at the end
so you can see that even with a hundred
percent alcohol you're going to need at
least three parts in five with the
common true parts to one recipe you need
at least 90% alcohol and if your only
source of alcohol in a hand sanitizer
recipe is less than 60 percent alcohol
you will never get 60 percent alcohol in
your final product so for example witch
hazel contains 15 to 30 percent alcohol
this will never give you more than 60
percent so all of these recipes which
have witch hazel as the only alcohol
containing component these will not
protect you and these ones even use
alcohol free witch hazel which obviously
is not going to work this one has a
tablespoon of pure witch hazel even if
this witch hazel has 30% alcohol you end
up with not 0.6 percent alcohol in your
final product this particular recipe has
10 mils of witch hazel and 10 mils of
isopropyl alcohol which actually could
work so if you're using a hundred
percent isopropyl alcohol and witch
hazel containing 30 percent you will
actually end up with sixty five percent
alcohol since they don't specify the
concentration of alcohol you need or the
concentration of alcohol in the witch
hazel I think they just got lucky with
their proportions with recipes
containing drinking alcohol drinking
alcohol typically only contains 40%
maxximum if you see the word proof that
means double the concentration so for
example 90 proof means 45% alcohol that
means that you need a minimum of a
hundred and twenty proof to get 60%
alcohol and this is incredibly rare so
if you're making your own hand sanitizer
recipe you need something that looks
more like this rather than like this so
using vodka generally won't work unless
you have very very high alcohol vodka 90
proof vodka isn't going to work rubbing
alcohol will work this recipe if you use
one and a quarter cups of a hundred
percent rubbing alcohol then you will
get 67 percent which will work but using
90 proof vodka will not all of these
recipes that say you can use rubbing
alcohol or vodka this only works if
you're using very high percentage vodka
vodka is not a good substitute for this
sort of thing unless you are using
undrinkable vodka I've calculated the
actual alcohol concentrations and a
bunch of these recipes that I found
online so you can see how weak your
final alcohol ends up being I'm going to
be ignoring the drops of essential oil
in these recipes because it'll only
increase the volume by a really small
amount so this recipe recommends using
60% or higher if you use 60% you will
get 40% alcohol for this recipe to give
you a final concentration of at least
60% you'll need at least a 90% alcohol
product this next one which was very
popular uses four parts aloe vera gel to
one part 70% alcohol and this gives you
a final concentration of 14% alcohol
this one is 1/3 rubbing alcohol
one-third aloe vera gel one-third witch
hazel assuming there's no alcohol in the
witch hazel which is probably the case
you end up with 33% so the reason we
don't use pure alcohol to sanitize our
hands and surfaces is because firstly
alcohol evaporates very quickly and so
if it's mixed with something water-based
that means that it evaporates slower it
has a longer contact time with the germs
and so they're more likely to die the
other reason is that if you use a
hundred percent alcohol sometimes the
outside of a microbe will become
hardened to further damage and so having
a bit of water in there is important but
if you have too much water you will end
up with an ineffective product because
you don't have enough alcohol and again
it's the concentration of alcohol in the
final mixed product that
you care about even if you're using a
high concentration alcohol ingredient
that doesn't mean that you can just
dilute it as much as you like this one
uses seven parts 70% alcohol where three
parts aloe vera gel this gives you a
final concentration of forty nine
percent alcohol a third of a cup of
isopropyl alcohol with a quarter cup of
moisturizing ingredient this one gives
you 57 percent as your final
concentration this one uses one
tablespoon of alcohol with a minimum of
60 percent in 8 ounces of pure aloe vera
gel if you use a hundred percent alcohol
you end up with about six percent
alcohol in your final product so with
these recipes even if you have pure
alcohol you need at least 60% of your
recipe most of your recipe to be that
alcohol so the recipe you're using is
vital to giving you that high
concentration that you need to kill
coronavirus this next one uses one cup
aloe vera gel to 2/3 of a cup of rubbing
alcohol of 70% or higher with a hundred
percent rubbing alcohol you end up with
a final concentration of forty percent
if you use 70 percent you end up with 28
percent
this one has rubbing alcohol as an
option I'm not even going to talk about
that this one uses two tablespoons of
91% isopropyl alcohol and three
tablespoons of aloe vera gel this gives
you a final concentration of 36% this
recipe uses one teaspoon of rubbing
alcohol in a quarter cup of aloe vera
gel and then distilled water to get it
to your desired consistency with a
hundred percent rubbing alcohol the
maximum you can get with this is five
percent alcohol and alcohol is not
optional in a hand sanitizer noir I've
made an alcohol concentration calculator
where you can put in the percentage of
alcohol you're using the recipe you're
using and it will calculate the final
alcohol concentration for you I've put
the link in the description of this
video
this recipe is interesting because it
actually uses diluted soap so the reason
soap is recommended for dealing with
coronavirus is because the soap
molecules can dissolve the envelope
around the virus much like how alcohol
does the other reason so it works so
well is that you don't have to worry
about whether or not your hands are too
greasy and that grease is protecting the
microbes so it will just get rid of the
whole blob of grease with the microbes
inside it
leaving soap on your hands is
also not a great idea there are quite a
lot of studies that have found that
using soap and water to wash your hands
is more damaging to your skin than using
an alcohol-based hand rub and Steven and
I went through a lot of these studies in
our video on alcohol and skin cats so
using soap in a hand sanitizer recipe
where you're not going to rinse your
hands afterwards is probably going to
lead to a lot of irritation so I
wouldn't recommend this so a couple of
extra tips for using hand sanitizers
effectively using a tiny blob of hand
sanitizer usually isn't that effective
you need to have enough to coat your
hands entirely and it should stay wet
for about 20 seconds so that's another
advantage of using a commercial product
usually it has a dispensing mechanism
and it tells you exactly how much you
need so for example this is one to two
pumps you should allow your hands to air
dry after you've applied the hand
sanitizer and not wash it off because
again that alcohol needs to have a long
enough contact time with the viruses and
bacteria to kill them so I hope this was
a useful video for you all I know that
it can be quite scary because we're in a
situation where we don't have that much
information but there's a saying that
goes just because science doesn't have
all the answers doesn't mean you can
fill in all the gaps with whatever crap
you have that is paraphrased make sure
you check health authorities for the
best advice on how to protect yourself
and your loved ones if you like this
video click the thumbs up you can
subscribe and also click the
notification bell leave me a comment
letting me know what you want me to talk
about next you can also follow me on
instagram at lab math and beauty signs
and check out my blog for lots and lots
of nerding out about beauty I will see
you next time where I'll probably be
talking about how to make your own
toilet paper